is that yeah and and and ask or not ask
and be like oh man which means like oh
you grew up a lot that was completely
[__] ask if you have hair down there
yeah yes asking if you got hair but
actually an old lady like howon would do
that yeah it was it it was like
free-for-all it doesn't matter fre all
yeah I kept that [__] in like that was
weird and then now you're saying I was
like is this a [__] Korean thing no
for sure it is is this one of those
Dolly llamas suck my tongue things in 5
4 3 2 1 what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of The Genius brain
podcast I'm in the orange seat today for
those who are watching on the video side
which is usually Gilbert's chair when we
do the MMA podcast but we have two
guests we have double Ed double trouble
double e double D's big old titties
let's do it baby Ed Park squared Ed Park
Square dude happy [__] I'm going
keep saying Happy New Year all the way
through January yeah why not yeah why
not yeah man yeah let me tell you this
though so we so Joe talked about this
this on I so I said enter this uh video
the other day yeah I was like what the
[__] is going on here let me tell you
something I'm not going to post any of
the footage because it did get recorded
just because I'm I'm going to let this
go but who was recording it by the way
uh it was Joe's wife Hannah okay okay
so bad things tend to happen right I
look I've never I've never been this
type of angry in a very very long time
yeah so uh I go to
Hawaii everything is fine we're shooting
stuff great when we come back first of
all number one I never take a taxi right
yeah but because where I had to go was
so close the taxi was more convenient
cuz it's right there okay so either way
it was going to be the same price as a
uber so I was like why the [__] not wait
wait so you had to to use an app though
to call that taxi no it's just right
there you just walk oh okay okay so it's
one of those taxis that are waiting so
if you guys fly into LAX there's a
specific section only for Ubers and
taxis now right so we walked over there
we get into a taxi the taxi guy who
Flags him down he goes go into the
Yellow Cab we're walking up there there
was actually a car before him that was
like a great uh Toyota Corolla and the
guy's like all right he's grabbing our
bags and he puts in the trunk and we're
like oh they told us to go to the Yellow
Cap and immediately he goes okay well
which is it and you know attitude right
off the bat off jump I should have just
been like okay we're going to go into
the Yellow Cap but he already put our
bags in and then our destination point
is only a 8 to 10 minute drive so I'm
like you know what [__] it we'll just
get into the car he's going to drop us
off who cares right and he's like
freaking out he goes which is it I was
like I don't think he saw you because
you were hiding behind the van so he
told us the yellow C but we can go with
you it's okay so we get into the uh to
the
taxi and so the guy is already irritated
he's an old Armenian man and listen I'm
not saying stereotypes are real but let
me tell you something Armenian
stereotypes are kind of real he's a
little angry right so the guy comes up
and he goes address what's the
address I give him the address he goes
what is the address like like this I'm
not even exaggerating he's yelling and
it's me Joe and his wife Hannah and I'm
like I just gave you the address I give
it to a big he goes what is address like
that I'm like okay you [__] old
geriatric [__] and I'm being very calm
right now CU he's yelling at me yeah not
even exaggerating did he call you bro
hey bro hey bro what his address right
what his address so I was like hey if
you put it into your phone you could
take us there he goes how do I get there
how do I get there what do you mean
you're the taxi driver exactly he goes
how do I I was like
put it into your phone he goes you put
it in so he gives me his phone I type in
the address that I have to get to and he
goes and he starts driving first of all
this guy's driving like a [__] Maniac
yeah he's swerving in out cursing people
a mother of [__] [__] [__] you two
times [__] [__] like that he literally
says that by the way he goes [__] you
two times so he's like swerving we get
out the car we're looking at the place
that he's dropping me off at I'm like
and as we're driving he goes oh by the
way uh this is not La you're taking me
to this is uh was it uh seula or some
[__] like that I'm like and I'm already
irritated I go cool story just drop us
off and so he's driving he takes us to
this random [__] spot and he goes
we're here I'm like hey this is not the
address he turns around he goes this is
what it is like that wow this is the
third fifth sixth time he's screaming at
me wow and at this point I'm still calm
I'm like hey and then Joe he goes hey
you know what you're being rude we're
actually don't feel we don't feel safe
in this cab from the way that you've
been driving you've been yelling at us
so we're just going to get off he
because we probably should have gotten
another cab right he goes yeah maybe you
should like that he goes where he goes
where's my money yeah like that he
dropped us off 4 minutes away from the
airport what the [__] is he talking
about wow he's screaming like where's my
money where's my money at this point I
red line I'm [__] pissed right so
this guy I'm like [__] you shut the [__]
up I was I'm not paying you [__] [__]
you drop the sauce at the wrong spot he
turns at his car he goes you sit here
dude his phone he had three other
addresses before ours so he was going to
three different spots before our address
wow so I'm telling him like look at your
phone look at your phone this are these
are three different addresses before
ours what are you talking about and he's
just screaming at us and then Joe starts
going off he's screaming he goes like
[__] you like [__] what the [__]
is your problem you're a [__] Maniac
you're [__] crazy so we get out Joe
stays in the car because he won't open
the trunk so he won't open the trunk Joe
stays in the car before he drives off
with our stuff cuz you could tell he's
about to yeah so he stays his wife stays
in I come out to the other side and I
grab his phone cuz he's shoving it in my
face I look wrong address this is my
address you took us to the wrong spot
and he gets outside and he [__] tries
to swing at me oh my God so he pulls out
the car and he [__] raises his fist
to swing at me and you know here's the
thing the guy's like 50 something years
old is this [__] Grandpa trying to to
fight me right like are you out of your
[__] mind and by the way I looked
ridiculous like this is my air I have
like a neck pillow around my neck you
know what I mean and so we get out and
then he tries to swing at Joe oh no so
he Tred to swing at both you guys so I
think at this point I been very [__]
patient the verbal [__] and now he
actually tried to hit us yeah twice yeah
so at this point Hannah starts recording
and he gets kind of gets in our face he
goes you made a mistake you made a
mistake and I think he's already kind of
calming down because we I I started
screaming at him like like an inch away
from his [__] face screaming at to
get in the [__] car I saw he he made
a fist as well yeah he already tried to
swing at me a few times so when I saw
that fist again yeah yeah I shoved them
and I shoved him light that checked him
super quick his moood went down
immediately yeah that was the moment
where he's like I got to go I got go I
got to go and then he was like fine get
your stuff he's suddenly really calm
after you dress just try to punch me
twice you know what I'm saying and this
whole ordeal was just so [__] nuts
like I don't understand what the [__] is
with this guy he had that he he was kind
of posturing with that why I aut you
[__] my favorite part of this
[__] is that I'm so sweet now as a guy
in the video I say this one line that
had me dying laughing I said I said
you're a terrible
person I don't know why I yelled at I
said you're a terrible person I see that
part yeah in the video I say you're a
terrible person because I was so like I
don't know what to think cuz he's like I
see an older gentleman I look at I see
my father right right I mean rightfully
so he did look like he was kind of you
know on the older side he had the gra
and yeah I was like I just see my dad I
see the Immigrant story I see everything
but I can't let this dude just sock me
you know what I mean I mean it was
completely out of line I mean I I
totally I know we didn't bring it up I
really thought he just thought Asians
weren't going to do [__] no but this is
what I feel like I truly believe that no
I 100% agree yeah and me and Joe were
talking about this too I'm
like cuz I'm not a small guy yeah you I
mean I'm like 61 big dude I'm like I
wonder if he thinks that most Asian
people they they would kind of just take
it so he thought he could bully so when
he just got my and I pushed him he's
like oh [__] he might be black guy you
know
I you know maybe maybe too that like he
kind of like underestimated you guys
just because you guys were kind of in
you know raggedy clothes coming off the
airplane right we were very nice to him
up into that point we didn't
yell I'm pretty sure he thought you guys
were just some International dudes
coming straight from he's like I'm going
to [__] with these guys I've never heard
a taxi driver ask me for directions
right that was the first time I've ever
heard how did you get this job
[__] exactly here's the other
thing too right so we called this
company up to report him he like hey you
have a dangerous driver like he tried to
assault us all this other stuff you know
what they [__] said to us they go
well we saw his location he's at Lex so
there's no way he dropped you off oh and
we're like God he dropped us off 3
minutes from the airport so yeah you're
going to see he's at LAX like we don't
believe you what we're going to do we're
going to report it to LAX and just get
their account cut cuz that dude is
[__] not fit to drive out of control
man that to be yelling and then threaten
physical violence on top of that like
for for nothing for yeah he tried to get
paid from dropping me off in an Alleyway
like that's the wildest thing I've ever
experienced in my life how much how much
was uh was the uh was trying to charge
you for oh I didn't even see it cuz I
wasn't paying [__] okay he's like
fighting you over like five bucks it was
probably going to be like $7 it's like
are you out of your [__] mind dude
like get the [__] out of here I mean at
that point it's not even the matter of
the bill it's what he's doing and how
he's doing it right first of all he's
giving you an attitude he's like trying
to hit you and it's not even where you
guys were supposed to get dropped off at
M right so it's like all of that and
it's like what the [__] bro you expect
me to pay
it was so weird cuz I couldn't really
you never feel good about [__] like this
right especially at our age like I'm not
ever trying to fight somebody yeah so
even in the video I saw this [__] where
you could tell in my in my mind process
after I pushed him like my hand still
wasn't ready to fight cuz I wasn't sure
if I wanted to hit him of course of
course you feel already bad yeah I
pushed an older man yeah that you're
thinking of like you know getting
physical with somebody this age you know
yeah genius brain listeners this podcast
is brought to you bu better help my
friends how many times have I said it
mental health is mental wealth focus on
your mental health so you can focus on
everything else in your life I'll tell
you this when it comes to the new year
we tend to beat ourselves up because we
think that we have to go ahead and just
cross out that number that we wrote last
year saying 2023 scratch it out and
write a for because you didn't
accomplish anything that's a lot of
pressure my friends well guess what this
year's going to be a little bit
different around New Year we get
obsessed with how to change ourselves
instead of just expanding on what we're
already doing right maybe you finally
organized one part of your space and you
want to tackle another or maybe you're
taking supplements every morning and now
you want to actually eat breakfast too
therapy helps you find your strength so
you can ditch the extreme resolutions
and make changes that really stick if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get match with
the license therapist and switch
therapist any time for no additional
charge celebrate the progress you've
already made visit betterhelp.com today
to get 10% off your first money that's
betterhelp.com
Jus this happened to me a lot at the gas
station lot we saw we saw the videos I
mean yeah you can see the videos but it
was essentially these older white men
yeah who just see me and think that I'm
just an automatic [__] yeah so they'll
come in and like hey man like uh it's a
nice spot I'm thinking of buying it I'm
like okay right he's like yeah you know
you can get really cheap stuff at this
wholesale and I'm just P I'm just going
uhhuh uhhuh and then he goes hey what
the [__] is your problem huh I'm trying
to help you right what the [__] is wrong
with you and I'm like really shocked I'm
like what do you mean to help me like
it's like I could buy this whole store
[__] and then that's how yeah at
this point I was like you know what [__]
you and then he was he was utterly
shocked because why cuz I just he didn't
think Asian people do that [__] and so I
found out you know what if I go crazy on
every white person they'll stop [__]
with me and that's exactly what I did
pulling out your
penis I mean to be fair too to be fair
too like some of these people that you
were dealing with weren't necessarily
just like crazy people some of them are
racist too oh yeah oh yeah I've had
customers come in straight bald head
white
pride wow Baldhead with all the
swastikas yeah and the SS tattoos
another D same thing white pride across
his chest then I had a guy come in just
paying for gas and he put his wallet
down and there was a swasa stamped on
his [__] wall right so that's the
kind of [__] I deal with so if
I was in your position my PTSD would
have been like I'm going
crazy no but the thing is you know you
gotta you got to be careful right cuz
like if you match that energy you you
you get crazy with somebody who's crazy
it could quickly go through that's what
I'm saying though in my area these old
white men they're essentially harmless
you know they're not like they're not
crazy either but they come in because
they have nothing to do but [__] with
the
asany whole purpose was I'm want to pull
up to this liquor store gas station just
to [__] with this kid dude so there's
one guy comes up and he's he's in a work
truck something Plumbing right and he
and his cooworker come in and it's 11:00
a.m. and this guy is like kind of drunk
and he looks at me and he's like Hey
where's that little Asian lady and I'm
like are you talking about my mom oh no
he's like yeah where's she at uhhuh and
then I just looked at him and I didn't
blink cuz I wear contacts I have the
ability not to Blink and then he goes
what are you looking at I like what are
you looking it then he goes like this oh
no puts finger guns to my face I'm
behind the counter right
and I was like do that [__] let's do it
cuz I I'll [__] you up you fat
[__] started just going off and
then he goes someone ought to teach you
some respect and I'm like oh you you
drunk [__] it's 11:00 a.m. and
you're drunk and then he's like you well
[__] you you [__] go and when I hear
that I'm like yes green light and I was
like let's go outside right so you're
right I am a goo very accurate very
accurate now we must fight to the death
so I go out there and I'm screaming at
him too right and then his co-worker
pushing me back and I could see this guy
like oh kind of shot cuz I'm going crazy
yeah right and then I said I said I will
360 roundhouse kick you in the [__]
Temple [__] walk away and he
walks away right and then Kung Fu his
coworker [__] no so his cooworker
standing there and he's like hey you got
spunk kid but I don't know if you can do
that in your ug
so that day was cold I was wearing Ugg
slippers oh my God I forgot I was like
ah [__] right but then I went up to him
anyway and I was like I need I'm going
to take your picture you can't come back
here [__] then he punched me in
the face oh wow with my phone yeah and
then so the picture I have of him is
like this wow yeah it's on my in I'll
I'll post it up so [__] yeah it's like
this and then I was just so [__]
heated that I looked up I called the the
plumbing number mhm then I I posted that
[__] online the weirdest [__] thing
his wife liked the post that I posted
about she hates him for sure yeah I for
sure remember saying that's why you're
drunk that's why your kids hate you
that's why you're probably divorced and
I was just saying [__] I don't know but
it was like I looked at people like that
like yeah you nobody likes you that's
why you going around [__] his wife dude
that's the ultimate [__] event I know
you should have [__] the [__] no but
but the thing is it's like in those
situations you got to you got to stand
up for yourself right otherwise they're
going to keep they'll do it again
they'll find the next Asian guy do it
was like when my pops you know had his
store in in South Central I mean you
know you had dudes trying to check him
all the time right come in try to like
steal try to like press up on him and so
my Pop's go-to was like he put his foot
up on the counter start tightening his
laces I'm going to [__] you up now and
then these guys think oh [__] this dude
knows karate [__] they're like hey
it's it's cool you know a lot of like uh
people back in the day they would say
that though they thought that every
Asian person knew like martial arts so
if they saw some [__] like let's say if
a guy was like tapping his knees or
something like oh [__] this guy's going
to [__] me up I didn't know you know
[__] um so we know somebody named Abe
ab's dad was know so years
ago so he grew up in uh like a city
right next to to where I grew up in
El right so elk and Sacramento pretty
close by well at the time there wasn't a
lot of Asian people there and his dad
was one of the people that was one of
the Asian dudes bu dad was also on the
football team he was really buff he
still has old man strength of his day M
well he was known to like carry around
[__] nunchucks and he would
beat what the [__] I'm not even Fu you
know how this is the 70s too right so
hot exactly
stereotypes not even making the [__] up
like we only found this out because a
used to work at a bank and then while he
was working at a bank there was a guy
that came up to him and was like hey do
you know so and so he goes yeah that's
my father and he goes you look just like
your dad he goes oh what's your dad up
to now he goes oh he works uh he works
at the fs in prison he goes man that
sucks that your dad's in jail he goes no
my assumed he's like no my dad works at
the prison he goes how long has he been
in jail he goes no my dad works at the
he goes dude your dad was a badass and
then he started telling him all these
stories like oh the stories he said was
but he was known as this guy he told a
very specific story too where he went to
this house party and somebody said some
type of racial slur to him so he took
went outside with his nunchucks and he
bashed up this dude's truck with it
[__] up the [__] headlights the
[__] front mirror the most [__]
gooiest way to destroy something is he
just walking around with the [__]
nunchucks around his neck like where
does he keep him like a [__] cornball
dude did a street fighter bonus level on
this [__] wow about coins started flying
out
sure you can but he was known for that
type of [__] crazy well I was actually
cuz you know like when older parents
tell you stories you're not sure what's
real or not and then when somebody
confirms it like that it's kind of weird
dude it's it's like you know like I said
my mom would always give me the gang
talk and I I and I couldn't see my dad
that way right but you know I grew up
playing baseball and my dad straight up
took my bat one day right and I'm like
what the hell right and I go to complain
to my mom I was like dude
I stole my
bat and then take care of some business
yeah and then she told me she's like oh
at the store like a couple vagrants or
whatever attacked our next door neighbor
the business next door and my Dad ran
out there with my bat and beat the [__]
out of these two guys and then that's
what I remember afterwards like he put
up this barbecue for us and this guy had
like a black guy and like a bandage on
his head and so I think he was super
grateful to my dad so I was like oh oh
yeah I'll buy another bat I mean wow
yeah I mean [__] was real back then
though bro like yeah my dad had straps
at the store cuz you know it was in a
gang neighborhood and and you you just
never knew like where it was going to go
that's the biggest reason why my dad
spent so much time in prison it's cuz he
had a gun and he's not supposed to yeah
felon yeah like yeah that was that's was
a pacifist though I think it's cuz he's
also a pastor right he was always like
very peaceful and then he had
as this like [__] raging child well
but your mom has to rage exactly you
know what I hate that my mom always says
to me that pisses me off she like I'll
do something that's very reminiscent of
her and she goes I don't know where you
learned that it's like [__] what the
[__] are you talking about you [__]
Maniac from you she goes where did you
learn how to say all these bad words in
Korean I'm like it's literally you
there's no way I learn this language
outside of you what the [__] are you
talking about yeah my mom tries to swear
that we don't share the same personality
like I might look like my dad but I for
sure have my mom's ADHD too yeah and the
thing is my mom you know she's got PTSD
from my dad cuz you know he's a piece of
[__] but I look exactly like him so that
I sometimes that's why I think our
relationship is so weird cuz my mom
always sees my dad in it kind of
triggers her yeah part of her therapy or
whatever is to just love me as me not
like a carbon copy like of my dad just
wake up in the morning Mom just scows at
your face [__] up to no good I'm just
going to work you look just like your
[__] dad come back she wouldn't let
me she wouldn't let me get
glasses like in the fifth grade you know
they do the public school eye test it
look more like your dad I'll look more
like my dad so you were just blind I was
blind until the 10th grade when my mom
was like okay you're in high school now
it matters so they got me classes dude
that's hella funny isn't that crazy so
you were just like the blind kid in
school I know I'm smarter than this I
just can't read the [__] on the board
like it's such a book room he wants to
sit at the front of the class no I just
can't see it's exactly what happened I
had to sit in the front that's so
[__] funny how weird of a move for
your mom that's so hey trauma is real
yeah no for I mean that's that's like
prime example of of like trauma and PTSD
manifesting do you guys did you guys
ever had this thing in elementary school
where uh they used to give you rewards
for like doing better on the
multiplication table or something like
that no bro mine [__] was write your
name on the board and check marks for
[__] getting in trouble that's what
iie [__] that's what I you know what so
[__] I remembered this this [__] trauma
it's not even that traumatizing but for
me I will always remember this so like
in third grade we're like doing the
multiplication table or it was like
second grade and on every Friday they
would do this this thing where if you
can go up the multiplication table
multiple times so 1 * 1 1 time two blah
blah blah two time and to keep doing
that the higher that you go you would
get more toppings for your ice cream for
what the [__] party or whatever they
gave you ice cream that often ice cream
Sundays for for uh on Fridays when they
would do that for the test so it would
be like what the [__] every Friday you
got maybe not every Friday maybe I just
ate ice cream every
Frid I think it was probably maybe once
a month and I just brought my own ice
cream even
still but they they had ice cream and I
just remember I was so [__] dumb like
I had no toppings but I was like the
fattest kid in the class and it made me
so sad cuz all these like skinny kids
they were so smart and they would just
like have all these [__] topping
sprinkles cherries like whipped cream
chocolate and I would just have like ice
cream and like one slice of banana cuz I
couldn't go up the multiplication D but
banana dude that's still like [__]
dope that you got ice cream that often
for I mean [__] if if that was a reward
I would have made maybe been better not
me dude I was just dumb with no ice
cream I you know the weird thing about
me is I was competitive about
math I I was like that you're you're
trying to fit The Stereotype huh I don't
know what it was cuz it was something I
was actually good at yeah okay like so
in my math class I was like really proud
that I was at the top of the no actually
you know when it comes to math um I was
actually like always one grade above but
then it was like once I got into junior
high and I started like really [__]
around yeah that's that's dude even even
getting into junior high like you have
to take a placement test um I got into
algebra in the placement test so I was
in class with like the eighth graders
coming into seventh grade but like two
three weeks into it I got dropped back
to pre- I just I was just not yeah I was
just not even doing anything I just
sucked at school dude like I I I
remember just like I think it my ADHD
was so bad oh yeah I couldn't [__]
Focus to save my [__] I didn't know
how to study I didn't understand the
concept of people sitting there reading
and memorizing [__] yeah bro when it
came to studying at that age it was like
there were times when I would actually
try to try like in my mind I'm like okay
I'm I'm going to try to like actually
study for this test and I like open up
the book and I'm a [__] this I'm going
smoke a
bowl oh my god do you guys did did you
guys ever have like in elementary school
one of those weird kids that just always
stuck out there was this one kid that of
course of course everybody everybody
knows like that one kid I had this one
kid that would always eat raw hot dogs
ooh well like just bring a pack of
[__] hot dogs I remember he would
just sit on the wall the wall ball wall
like towards the end which I don't know
make any sense because that's the most
dangerous wall to sit next to right cuz
a ball is flying at it all the time and
he would just get this cold packet of
hot dogs with the hot dog juice and
everything he would whip it out and he
would just eat it and you be eating hot
dogs so
this glimy gobler dude just [__]
going at that [__] his his mom just gave
him a pack of hot dog pack of hot dogs
and then I remember one time just coming
up to I'm like hey how come you don't
heat up the hot dogs yeah right he goes
it's just as good when it's cold and he
had like a little southern accent he was
like it's just as good when it's cold I
I'm from Sacramento so I don't know
where the [__] he was from his name was
Ryan it's just as good when it's cold
and he would just bite right into the
hot dog and I'm not going to [__] lie
to you I was like hey let me get
one no you could eat raw hot dog I know
but I remember that was the first time I
ate a cold hot dog and I did not like it
well I I don't think I've ever seen
anybody just bust out a [__] pack of
dogs just eat them out of the the whole
pack bro he just grabbed the whole pack
and he just cracked it open and started
eating raw hot dogs no there was this
one kid um when I was in elementary I
remember him distinctly still still even
to this day his name was Jeffrey skinny
white kid like stick stick thin right he
he used to come up and be like hey you
know you want to see something cool and
then it's like oh God no no it's sad
it's it's not disgusting it's sad
because I didn't realize at that age I
thought it was cool like he was saying
and he goes check this out and he go
like this and he'd pull his hair and
like just clumps would come out oh my
God so he's like try it and I'm like
what the [__] and then and then chunks
of hair would just come like you don't
even have to like pull hard it's just
did he have alopecia dude no no so I I
get to it and then and then like at at
lunch every single day this was his
lunch he had half um half a a slice of
wheat bread and three slices of
pepperoni in there that was his lunch
every single day oh God never ate it
always gave it
away hindsight I realized this
[__] was malnourished that's why
his hair was falling out so easily oh
and that's why he was so stick thin he
never ate he was sucked in like you know
cheeks like bone popping and his hair
would just [__] fall out and the
teacher didn't do nothing notice his
skeleton walking every day that's that's
like yeah that's what I'm saying it's so
[__] up if I was a teacher and I saw a
ghoul come in yeah first of all no
that's a good that's a good way to
describe what he looked like he looked
like a ghoul know there's our
mask Halloween yeah and and it's so
[__] sad that this dude I don't even
know if he's alive you what I mean but
then it was pepperoni and Wonderbread
though that has like good calories three
slices of pepperoni bro this dude hot
dog boy yeah he could have solved all
his problem that fool was handing out
cold hot dogs to everybody I was the
only one that ate it though yeah so yeah
that fu yeah that kid Jeffrey another
kid that stood out to me was um this guy
named Joe vuki and uh he he used to have
the mcgyver haircut with the you the
mullet yeah the mullet yeah with the
with the spikes and and he was always
quiet and weird but then like his dad
like did the kind of reputation got
around that his dad is kind of like a
tough guy like he's a boxer and stuff
and apparently he was training Joe
right people kind of picked on him cuz
he was quiet and like very shy and
softspoken but then one time I got into
a fight with like this guy and then like
one or two of his friends came in and
they try to jump me Joe vuki out of
nowhere came and helped me out and this
will [__] pieced him off like he he
[__] was like I was like oh [__] damn
why did why did he defend you I don't
know he just I guess he saw me you know
getting jumped I saw you pull hair out
of and I thought you were really
cool so back in the 90s that's [__]
up like when I was in Federal Way so now
Federal Way is like 50% Koreans or
something it's a huge Korean population
but back then it was a few of us and I
was the one Korean in sixth grade and
there was another Korean girl in the
other sixth grade grade class and but
you know lunch we play basketball
whatever and then um she was a tomboy
she played basketball every day at
recess and then I remember this Lebanese
kid whose family were
refugees um they got in a fight and they
were just started throwing hands like
hardcore and then I remember I stood
there shocked like oh and then like by
the time it was over like she had a big
scratch on her neck and [__] and then um
her mom owned uh a VHS rental store
right to get all their dramas and [__]
so I'm going in there with her and then
I look at the wall and it's her and
she's already got a black belt in
techwondo and her mom looks at me and
she was like why didn't you help my
daughter right what the and then my
mom's like what you didn't help a girl
at school and then these two Korean
women started berating me in this VHS
store like I thought these for Coran
drama she die I have nothing to do yeah
I was like oh [__] what the pce of a
[__] I like I mean by the time we were
in like seventh grade I kind of had a
crush on her but we moved away and then
she found me on Instagram like post
College She's a Lesbian so I was like oh
she took care of herself see yeah that's
why you didn't go and help her you
sensed it already no but like what you
like [__] what are you supposed to do
oh yeah I was 10 well not only that it's
two girls fighting no a dude oh a dude
and a girl was fighting oh that's what
I'm saying she was handling it herself
oh oh okay okay oh but she she had a
black belt though right that's why she
was [__] him up probably so she I
mean cuz she went home with these
scratches like yeah her mom was mad at
me for not it's like dude she beat him
up what do you want me to do can I tell
you this thing so I remember in high
school right oh not high school I'm
sorry Elementary School why I say High
School in elementary school there was
these two brothers that they were in
karate and then me and my brother were
in tewo well the tewo studio that we
went to when I was a kid was very very
serious cuz our tabing was from Korea so
he didn't have a lot of students cuz he
did play he did you know he wasn't very
nice yeah he was hard but everybody in
our in our studio whooped everybody's
ass cuz the people who did stick around
were [__] amazing and he would even
fly some of his students from Korea over
to train us oh wow it's the kind of tech
one though that was trained for the
military right yes so it's like Tango
[__] like that yeah so we would do that
type of stuff well this is such a it's
kind of bad kind of terrible so like
there was one time where so the older
brother was my brother's age and then
the younger brother was my age I don't
know I don't remember what exactly
happened but both those guys tried to
fight me and my brother which is very
weird I mean they don't know that we're
in Pondo and they're in karate but us
our us all four was a bunch of [__]
dweebs let's do this we got into a fight
in front of the school yeah right and
we're in elementary school but I
remember I back straight kicked the [__]
out of this kid and donkey kick [__]
blue dude when he got kicked in the gut
he just
went couldn't [__] breathe
backstraight kicking was like my
favorite [__] move especially because
in our studio we sparred hard even as
kids he we did the pum [__] that's what
would hit us with bamboo sticks the
[__] like I don't even know that was
legal but he would just like and we
would just have to hold it as I was
crying and so these kids don't know the
type of [__] Terror we go through in
that studio and then my brother beats
the [__] out of this dude too it was the
first time I ever saw my brother cool
ever never saw it again but dude you
terrible [__] story apparently that
kid had a heart problem oh no right and
then like a month later he [__] died
holy [__] so my brother beat up a kid
with a heart problem this guy [__]
assle taond number one yeah you should
have take a Tew not a Japanese
aot we had to defeat our oppressors dude
so this guy apparently the kid had like
a overgrown heart uhhuh and he was sleep
walking and then his mom woke him up
while he was sleepwalking and his heart
just stupped an irregular heartbeat oh
my God that's terrible passed away
imagine the [__] guilt that mom must
feel like oh for sure like she she's
probably thinking I killed my own child
no they thought my brother did cuz I
told everybody I told everybody brother
you passed away hey you know what it
could have what happened it was a death
touch it comes out punched him in the
heart my brother did that one thing to
the next five points but that [__] I
mean you got to understand we're kids
though so we all wanted to show our
Karate Kung Fu movie I I get it I get it
like yeah my my experience with tondo
was was pretty whack because like I I
went into it you know I asked my mom
like hey can I can I get into teeko so I
could learn cuz you know everybody
thought it was dope as [__] and then I
remember getting to like yellow belt and
then uh the this Hon in in a sparring
session um was like okay you're going to
spar a brown belt I was like okay that's
like what four levels above a yellow
belt right why would he make you do that
yeah I don't know but you only did a
belt above us we never went that right
that's what it was it was either same
belt or a belt one one above right so I
was like okay it's terrible [__] this
short ass kid who's like comes to my
chest so I'm like are you serious yellow
belt yellow belt against this guy I'm
like doesn't even matter that he's a
brown belt these guy's [__] coming to
my chest so I just basically Shear
kicked him yeah I just I just kept like
kicking him down cuz I felt bad yeah all
right sit down Green Belt
a girl I'm like are are you [__]
serious right now bro like you make me
[__] fight a [__] and you make me
fight a girl and then so with the girl
like I didn't even do anything I just I
just like just postured and just just
just like bouncing around you know and
then she would just kind of like kick me
after that day I was like I quit this I
was like this is [__] whack as hell
dude I would have kicked the [__] out of
that I don't ever lose I don't give a
[__] I never lose I never lose oh step
in this mat with me yeah hey man once
you step on this [__] mat that [__]
turns into a dick I just [__]
spitting HEI that thing is though like
if she came at me aggressive maybe you
know I might have I might have like you
know thrown a kick or two but like she
was very timid too and she didn't like
really want to hit me so I was just I I
just felt bad the whole time and I'm
like what is this guy [__] making me
doing man like why why am I fighting a
[__] [__] maybe he was trying to
boost their confidence but not knowing
it was going to destroy yours yeah I got
in trouble by my sabonim because I
couldn't stop farting during push-ups so
every time I do a push-up I kept farting
cuz this is during the time I didn't
know what lactose was you know drinking
cereal in all that [__] ice cream you
were getting it was cial so you know but
I couldn't stop farting and got so mad
at me every time I did a push-up he got
that bamboo stick and he kep hitting me
in the [__] ass that's [__] up that
he had a bamboo stick he hit you dud he
hit us with that [__] so much Kendall
class yeah he would beat the [__] out I
couldn't stop farting the problem is the
whole class got in trouble because they
couldn't stop laughing cuz if you're if
you're hitting somebody in the ass and
every time a fart comes out who's not
going to laugh right and he got more and
he's Korean yeah so he's getting more
and more Angry he kept hitting me keep I
kept
farting and he got so [__] mad to the
point where I had to do like like
hundreds of push-ups until like to the
point where he grabbed the back of my
belt to help me get up cuz my arms were
so tired so he would grab the back of my
belt and he would just force me to do
these push-ups constantly did he ever
cuss at you in Korean all the time
especially
Mee dude I went to when when I was
growing up here in LA and um I was at
this school and my teacher was Korean
right oh you you went to school in La
when you were younger like when I was
like all the way up till second grade
wow okay so this was like in at this
point Granada Hills okay okay so you're
in the valley yeah I remember it's
called vano Street school uhhuh and then
my second grade teacher ended up being a
Korean woman right and which was super
interesting I mean everything's in
English but one day I got in trouble for
something and then she started screaming
at me in Korean and I was shocked I was
she went full mom mode on you Jos and
then I was like oh and then nobody knew
what she was saying right but to me it
was like oh [__] like I was s trouble
yeah I got in trouble
she clearly communicated to my parents
yeah I mean getting yelled at in Korean
is different for sure in an American
public school that's [__] crazy
that's how you know you're like oh [__]
I'm in trouble dud you know as we're
talking about this I think my tewo
teacher was kind of abusive dude oh for
sure you
think what you mean you think bro come
on man they wouldn't I'm surprised that
the parents were cool with that [__]
well they're all Korean yeah if you're
Korean that's not
is there was like there was a couple
kids who weren't there was this one
black kid that dude was [__] funny as
[__] he used to make me laugh so [__]
hard and there was other Filipino kid
named Joshua he was the best out of all
of us he was so [__] good yeah um was
he a b boy too cuz usually I remember
his hair too he had like the B cut he
was so [__] good and the and the uh
the black kid he was just such a goofy
kid he would always say like we were
like he'd be like K his [__] wrists
were all curved and [__] that F was
definitely
gay
like before we knew what gay was I was
like there's something off about this
kid he's a little zesty he's a little
zesty a little too happy something about
him but I like him a lot yeah but every
everybody was just that I don't know
that's I mean it kind of makes sense why
it didn't last cuz I felt like most
Studios lasted because they were just
giving belts constantly for free like I
so I missed my red belt stripe to Black
Belt I never got a black belt but guess
what he only did that test once a year
so if you miss it you couldn't get a
black belt I had the flew so I couldn't
take the test and I was like can I take
the test later he goes no you got to
wait a year so he was that he never gave
Free Belts ever that's crazy so like
even this one time where so in order to
get my green belt striped to a blue belt
we had to do this fool would have you
know what I'm not even sure if other
people had to do this [__] I had to do a
jumping sidekick over two
people like this you know when you put
ass to ass yeah yeah yeah yeah so they
made we had to do a jumping sidekick and
make a board right so first of all we're
kids but so you guys didn't have to do
this [__] huh no I didn't have to long
jump yeah we had to do a jumping
sidekick like like [__] in the movies
and break like a poster just like a logo
still
said yeah so I did that I broke the
board right then for the final one I had
to do a jumping back kick not over
people but break the board I miss it I
[__] gash open my whole foot on the
edge of the board all the way through
I'm bleeding all over the place so I'm
then he whoops you with the and then he
my feet starts hitting he like now
P so I miss this [__] I'm [__] crying
right and I already did the other one
pretty well this is the only time I saw
kindness in him he let me get my blue
belt so I just had to punch a board and
break it because he saw the [__]
stitches I had to get in my [__] foot
but then now like nobody had to do this
[__] cuz you guys tell me your stories I
hear other people techwondo stories it
was really fun well like you know I did
it at church you know Church a lot of
Korean churches had tewo programs with
hung I got in trouble my very first
sparring sensor so you only got The Spar
when you hit the get the yellow belt and
then I didn't know that you're supposed
to use tech one that that we're just
supposed to
fight take down in the first he goes
like Jim sh and I just sock the kid in
the face right in the [__] nose he's
like shocked he's like oh my God I just
went wow punched the kid in the face
[__] nose bleeding cuz I thought we
were just going to fight yeah yeah like
no
boxing only Techo stuff I had no idea
all kicks yeah I have so many bad
stories just because like I'm ADHD and
Korean people like structure dude but
you were in it for a minute if you got
up to the red black belt oh I wasn't it
for a hot second my brother was really
good too and then we did um he got
really mad at me cuz I kept messing
around and sparring he put a body shield
on me and he kept [__] back straight
kicking me in the gut your brother or
oh wow so he put the shield on me you
want to [__] around so he kept [__]
backra like donkey kicking me all over
the studio turned you into a punching
bag yeah so just to teach me a [__]
lesson that's not normal huh yeah was it
was it was it was it you in particular
that he was always like you know gun me
mainly I think he believed in you he
believed in you he beat the [__] out of
or he was just bigger so he's like I'm
going to pick on this kid right here for
sure oh he's [__] farting in my class
my my cardio kickbox in class was in a
Korean K1 kickboxing okay and um all the
other cardio classes is like these
Latino women right cuz they a lot of
Latinos live in K toown and then so I'm
the only like Korean dude except for the
instructors but I came in there I was
this is when I was like 240 yeah right
it was the same thing these guys were
pushing me cuz they wanted me to lose
weight so I had to do [__] that everyone
else didn't have to do and so one of the
exercises I had to put my arms up and
every free little Mexican lady came in
to give me a one two to the
stomach I mean my belly was like coming
out to here and so I was like this good
for
[Laughter]
you I don't know how the hell you guys
handled that type of authority man I was
never good with that I mean I don't know
this guy could beat my ass and kill me
at any even still yeah I know even still
though like even still dealing with that
kind of [__] when I was growing up if
somebody I felt like dises respected my
instant reaction is to Rebel even if I
get my ass whoop it don't matter my [__]
was straight up fear okay yeah I mean I
was scared of my dad it was my dad who
taught me this way and then the H at
church they actually kicked the [__] out
of me for not ining to them not bowing
down to the scene that's true there was
there was definely a lot of that hazing
[__] going on my grandma was the one
that was taking us cuz her apartment was
next to the the techwondo studio that
she would encourage that [__] she' be
like yeah [__] He's Crazy his ass so
she would just be over here just [__]
cheering yeah but like even when I would
play team sports like like for example
my basketball coach like he was from the
hood right and this dude always would
[__] tell me I have an attitude
problem like bro he would spend
halftimes just grilling me out no no
game plan no oh oh edre you think you
missed a bad you're going to get shot
you g to I was like this dude telling me
I'm going to get shot oh my God yeah
he's like you think you bad H you going
to get shot and then like he would kick
me out during PR get the [__] out of the
gym and then I get out Park get your ass
back here just tell you get the [__] out
of the gym you don't get out of the gym
you come back here right now got ADHD
too dude and like I I didn't respond
well to that my my response wasn't oh I
got to get my [__] together my response
was man [__] you too then you know I'm
out of here like I don't need to deal
with this [__] but yeah that that's
how was always for me man I mean this
guy was beating my ass dude this guy was
literally [__] me up dude all over
the [__] place my brother never got
in trouble my cousin never did also too
I I will say though was it ab's dad with
theud ab's dad used to [__] me up though
dude ab's dad was so [__] mean dude
this guy used to wake us up in the
morning by calling us [__] so so he
got in trouble by my aunt because it was
a Saturday and then the middle kid he's
like my age we would wake up and he was
like good morning retards like that and
then his wife wife my aunt was like hey
you can't call them [__] like you
can't say those things he's like a tough
ass but with his wife soft as hell yeah
cuz he loves her right right right so he
would also call us dumb asses so he
switched from [__] to dumb asses so
good morning dumb asses and then she's
like what the [__] and so he eventually
switched it to ding heads oh so that was
like his he'd be like good morning ding
heads I remember he hated saying it cuz
he always had to make that little
adjustment in his head but he was super
[__] rough too with us all of us man
but you you know uh I'm sure you guys
had your stories with this too but you
remember like growing up and this might
sound [__] like completely left field
and wild to some of y'all who who aren't
Korean or Asian but uh when we were kids
and like we would see like our dad's
friends uncles or whatever they come up
to you and they'd grab your dick oh yeah
what is that yeah and and and ask or not
ask and be like oh man which means like
oh you grew up a lot that was completely
[__] ask if you have hair down there
yeah yes asking if you got hair but
actually an old lady like Hony would do
that yeah it was it it was like
free-for-all it doesn't matter yeah it's
I kept that [__] in like that was weird
and then now you're saying I was like is
this a [__] Korean thing for sure it
is is this one of those Dolly llamas
suck my tongue things no no
no well they never they never actually
like did stuff like that but it was like
one of those things where they just like
oh you got a little hair
no no no there was a grab like they
would come and [__] feel it like
yours might be a little different you
know I had the tug you what yo a a tu a
tug from old lady I never had touch but
I got the comments like that's a little
different did your dick get a little
bigger or you know did you get pu some
[__] so so like yeah the the the uncles
would be like Oh Come here
like right like and that would be a sign
of affection of like hey let's see how
how big you you're growing I think I was
like 3 years old I don't know how you
were the [__] hey man y'all were
laughing at my
stories like last year when it happened
myo stories are weird you guys got
groped by the Korean Community David you
were abused okay oh dude that guy
grabbed my dick too yeah you never had
the dick grab you never had ain't nobody
grabbing my dick okay in the comments
for anybody who are listening or
watching this please if you're Korean
please please chime in on this I I know
like I saw like I do remember other
people like they would like Ball tap
them or something like oh Mar c or
whatever no it was it wasn't like like a
[__] fondling your balls type [__] it
was more like they cuff and then just
like kind of give a little shake
like like it's a
[__] like let's let's see let's see
that jiggle action oh okay my god dude
am I going to have a
boyfriend yeah it like you know I didn't
know how to feel back then like I was
like what the [__] is I guess it's if
everybody's getting it it doesn't feel
like you're being targeted yeah no no no
it wasn't it wasn't just cuz they didn't
do that to the girls they like oh you
got a nice
[__] they only did it to the guys it
was only the guys yeah it was only the
guys and so like yeah it wasn't just
like being singled out if all the kids
that are there like yeah they' be like
oh you know let me
see it almost felt like a ride of
Passage it is yeah that's like a man
exactly it's it's them basically saying
oh let's see how far you're progressing
towards becoming a man type [__] well
that's also cuz Boys in Korea they all
get circumcised in middle school or high
school right oh do they there was a
while where like a lot of um babies
didn't get circumcised so when they got
older that's when dudes get circumcised
wow okay so that was one of those write
of passages for a whole generation of
Korean men cuz they would all get their
[__] foreskin cut off together [__]
that like oh it feels a little lighter
you got the work done had [__] in the
Google I think that's why that kind of
endearment comes from like we're broke
so [__] weird dude yeah funny you
guys say that there was a dude that
ended up staying at the the techwondo
studio until it closed and he became
like a third degree black belt or
whatever this guy I won't say his name
but I remember he got his dick
circumcised later on in life and I
thought it was just the funniest thing
ever because it was just like why now
dude yeah like you're already like 19
years old dude I and this fo got his
dick and remember he couldn't come to
the tewo studio for like 2 weeks cuz his
dick was in pain well they got the
stitches so they got to make sure that
you know they don't get excited or you
know it gets stimulated and I thought it
was hilarious cuz I knew somebody who
was like that too yeah I I knew another
dude he got his circumcised at 16 why
yeah yeah I don't know Koreans are like
think it's okay at any time of your life
apparently why would why would you opt
to do that at that point at just be
comfortable with your turtleneck at that
point and and his dad was a doctor so
it's like you're a doctor you think this
is a good idea right now what the hell
yeah no [__] that so interesting [__]
that but you know when you're younger
though I know like people would
definitely at the time because in the in
the United States a lot of people get
circumcised everywhere [__] else it's
like not much of a thing it's not a
thing right like in Europe and all this
other [__] and I remember I was talking
to a girl who's European and she was the
one that told me that is weird that
people in the states get their dick cut
I'm like and I felt
seen cuz I still have my turtleneck oh
you do yeah I wasn't circumcised so I
was like what the [__] really cuz I
always felt self-conscious about she
goes no like that's weird like why would
you guys cut that [__] [__] off yeah
even even I don't understand why like
there there's no purpose there's Absolut
it's it's an aesthetic thing there's
absolutely nothing like health related
about it yeah you got to clean it a
little extra you me pull the little
elephant skin back back yeah fill it up
with water like a balloon and then you
just I read on the news a God
damn hey when you're younger you do
weird things with your dick I used to
like pull the forkin open and I would
let the shower like it fill it up I
would let it and I was just like Let It
Go and the water would come out of my
forkin like a slug spitting water yeah
hella fun dude as a kid I was like oh I
can't wait to
shower I will just keep doing it over
and over I I read on the news that there
was a guy who who sued his doctor who
circumcised him as a baby cuz now he's
saying in his adult life there I
remember this article so clearly cuz it
was like the sensation on the tip of my
tongue is for sure not as sensitive as
someone who's
uncircumcised and then he was like years
of masturbation has worn off the feeling
oh wow so he's suing the doctor for that
yes so he trying to sue the doctor for
that is ridiculous did he did he did he
I don't know it's not like I caught up
with I wonder what he's up to if he won
the oh [__] no but that's why these days
there's like a movement of like anti-
circumcision yeah Andrew was was he was
he yeah okay yeah and and it's
understandable it's understandable it's
like well I'm okay of like doing surgery
on my kid like if I don't have to right
why would I need to right exactly and
apparently there's just a ton of like
accidents that happened to babies
because of botched circumcision I'm okay
dude it was an episode on uh Law and
Order SVU like these two set the twins
one of them had a botched uh
circumcision now these stories are based
off real stories apparently but in the
dramatization what a psychologist did to
the other kid was turn her into a girl
and say you're a girl and then so the
parents had to treat her like she's a
girl growing up and then by the time
she's you know going through puberty
she's like what the [__] like I'm not a
girl yeah yeah so apparently that's
based off a true story and it's an
episode ofra what the [__] but
circumcision is also based in religion
as well too so a man guys keep your skin
and fill it up with water that's like
one of my like my most F memories
dude why is he in the [__] shower for
so long I'm making water
balloons I remember in kindergarten in
kindergarten our school had a swimming
pool and so like every month or so we'd
all go out to the swimming pool but then
cuz we're just babies like kids we would
all just get undressed together in the
classroom and put on our swim trunks and
that's when I saw my first uncircumcised
yeah it was weird for me when I first
saw it I what is that it it's an Indian
yeah it's F elephant trunk no but it was
there the the tip was gone it was just
like like what is that and I'm like and
then I said hey yo hold
up me real quick seriously I'm like like
that looks like like an ante eater or
something you got to flick it like what
is that dude it is the natural way your
penis is no I know but of but but you
know when when you see your own dick and
your circumcised and you see that for
the first time it's very weird I
remember I saw my my uh cousin's dick
and then he didn't have his uh winter
vest on his Sweater Weather wasn't there
and then I was like the first thing I
thought was doesn't that hurt cuz like
if fabric touches it doesn't it hurt cuz
it's just exposed like if my thing's
exposed and it's like and it hits fabric
that's hurts point of that lawsuit is
that sensitivity still your guys is just
like half numb I bet you sex for you is
like awesome bro that's what I said
remember I told you the first time I had
sex I just put it in and I was like I'm
having a good time but the girls were
having a terrible time but that's that's
do you but do you even have to put it in
you already put it in when
it he I just put it in that's why
whenever I inserted I was like dude this
is amazing that's why you guys have to
do so much work yeah yeah it takes a
while actually yeah that is true huh you
uncircumcised dicks are probably more
sensitive cuz our dicks are chafing all
the time on oh is it yeah that's [__]
terrible no it's not chafing but you
know it's rubbing against like whatever
cloth whatever yeah it's just I have a
warm blanket over mine all the time
that's why I understand like how
[__] go commando in jeans and
[__] you know like dude your dick is
[__] rubbing on the zipper like how
oh yeah sometimes like you can't there's
some uh underwears that just their
fabric gets all whatever it's like I
can't wear that [__] not just for my
waist or ass or anything but literally
chafing on the that's why like
circumcised penises you know like when
you shake off your dick that's very
important cuz we have extra skin that
once again it'll water balloon and
collect you got that Che you have you
have to shake it off you have to Shake
it Off do you give the side to side or
the up and down I cires circles right I
got to make this shirt dry dude if it's
not dry it'll stick on my pants and then
you start stinking I'm just like cuz I
remember when I was a kid like you know
like you don't think about like cleaning
your penis and then look TMI for a lot
of people out there but when you're a
kid you're just dirty as [__] and you
see like you know smma smegma and I'm
like what the [__] is this after that
water Ballo it all day dude so you guys
already know playing with it keeps it
clean right 100% dude and they the
people used to tell you like if you do
if more than two shakes that means
you're playing with your dick but when
you're not circumcised you got to shake
that thing about dude I [__] I don't
care about no [__] rule you shake it
till it's you know
yeah you better [__] go at it dude I
do it like I'm [__] like an
exorcism like I spray holy water in the
name of dude like you know in Middle
School like I swear to God like American
white people have like the craziest
pranks you know I'm going I'm in a
urinal with and I'm just doing this so
my hands are occupied with my pants and
my dick and a dude came up to me grabbed
my shoulders and just shook me left hand
right and I couldn't do anything if I
let go my [__] then it's even more
uncontrollable yeah God damn yet that is
a crazy prank [__] crazy as [__] what
a weird prank like who wins yeah what
the [__] was that who's winning Who's
Laughing the guy who was shaking me what
the hell you guys got
groped I'm over here getting assaulted
by a [__] 35-year old man just
beating the [__] out of me while my
grandma cheers me on yeah no so so you
know when I when I talk to my homies
about that it like all of them it
happened to them too and I was like yeah
we we definitely can't be doing that to
like our kids or yeah I'm not going to
do that that [__] yeah there's no right
of passage here either especially if you
know now that we're so Multicultural
like we do that in front of our other
friends I'm like what the [__] are you
doing it's like oh this is what we do
it's so different it's so different of
like how we grew up how we got
disciplined and like how these new kids
are growing up and getting disciplined
now it's like night and day I mean
obviously you know the parents now are
hopefully are are more educated and
better equipped to like properly deal
with their children rather than just
beat their ass if they do something
wrong yeah but you know there the shy
kicks dude yeah there there is there is
a part of me where I'm like ah you know
don't coddle them too much though like
you know what I mean you don't want to
yeah I think there's a fine balance like
if I look back at it I definitely would
tell my dad like not to throw a office
chair at me that's probably one of the
things I would tell him not to do like
it pops I don't think you should be
knock me out you know but I still
remember what that chair looks like and
we still have it in the house yeah like
to this day we still have it it's this
blue office chair it was my office chair
as a kid and then when he I remember
when he threw at me the back piece broke
off so it's just the round part that you
just sit on it's like a stool we still
have it dude my dad maglight my brother
like you know like a cop when they they
hold their mag lights like this right my
dad took a MAG light Bonk over that
godam that just hella heavy you know you
know what was the [__] one of the
worst like psychological
so if I brought him like a clothes
hanger like a metal one and I brought it
again the next couple times he's
like that was so last
we come on really you think that's you
think that's going to be good enough to
for your punishment all right let me try
again yeah I have to find your parents
ever like uh bring out their fist and
tell you to pun yourself in the face
I've seen I've seen another person do
that I hated that [__] my dad would just
bring out his knuckles he like punch
your in the face what kind of [__]
sick [__] is that dude Poggle is that
what and I wouldn't do it like hard
enough so he would just make me go
harder until he felt satisfied you guys
you guys ever uh make a fist at your
pops at a certain point nope I've the
only time I've ever got physical with my
dad was once and it was when I was old
and we never got into it again cuz I
think I just got tired of him like
physically being my ass yeah no you
definitely get to that point yeah the I
think the first time that I made a fist
at my pops he's like the [__] was that
as was
like cramp nothing he's like no you just
made a fist at me didn't you and I was
like no I didn't he's like what you want
to fight me I was like no no I didn't
make a fist and then he was like I saw
you make the Fist and that probably
pissed him off even more yeah I said
[__] this I turn around and I got
knocked
out that hit you the back of the head
yeah I woke up on the [__] ground I
was like what the [__] happened what did
your mom say I don't think my mom saw
cuz it was just me and my pops in the
room oh [__] so your mom know about this
I don't think so that's crazy your dad
would have been in trouble but but but
you know that's like that old school you
don't [__] disrespect me type [__]
right so you made the fist like that
[__] cab driver did to me dude why
I yeah that was I was like why I cuz you
know I think this was like when I was in
I don't know 12 13 years old so now I'm
kind of like feeling myself you know and
I feel like a more confident about
fighting and [__] and I'm like n you you
know we're not we're not going to be
doing that anymore we're not going to be
playing that game and then I I I learned
real quick I learned real quick like H
[__] he's still my was that the worst
you ever got your ass whooped by your
dad no no cuz the thing is I don't even
know what
happened I didn't even feel it I like no
I don't remember [__] I just [__] I I
I [__] I I landed like you know face
first on my stomach and I just like I I
opened my eyes I like what the [__]
happened I was just on the floor you
know what's so weird too like as we get
older and maybe not with your dad but
with my dad like I look at my dad and
then I see him like especially at the
wedding and I saw him and I was like I
can't believe if I let this dwe beat my
ass well come on man he's a senior
citizen now like he's oldo [__] nerd
like what's wrong with you man the
funniest [__] was like yeah that when
when you and your mom were dancing and
[__] and like having a good time how
your pops kept trying to say like yeah
your mom wants to go your mom feeling
sick she's feeling sick right now what
you talking about she's having a damn
good time [__] Maniac dude one time
my dad um challenged me to arm wrestling
for some reason your dad is so funny
dude wake up come on but I beat him I
beat him I was 15 right I was like yeah
[__] yeah after that he started being a
[__] [__] like a
bully he started making me come to the
store to just carry heavy [__] for him
oh you think you're so strong yeah he
kept saying that no you think you're
strong pick this up pick this up Pi hey
but that's impressive though to cuz I
like even at 15 my pops was built like
an ax I could I could never [__] beat
him in armrest I think by the time I was
15 my dad must have been on meth oh
that's
right meth arm and you were like f your
[__] face some of the [__] he would
make me do is meth people stuff like we
had a a organiz these pins yeah we had a
pond in our backyard right he made me go
in there and brush the [__] rocks
what the [__] like every individual Rock
and I'm like I don't get it why on her
and then I'm like thinking in my head
like is this because I beat you in arm
wrestling kind of thing and then day you
hurt your dad's Pride yeah oh yeah
that's massive hit to the [__] Pride
one day he's just [__] metad being an
[__] to me again and then he Yanks
out the Xbox he Yanks out like uh this
other stuff I don't even know what he's
mad about and he's [__] tossing it
right and the thing about the Xbox is
that my sis that's actually my sister's
she worked all somewhere at the gas
station to save up and buy it my dad
[__] throws right that's why I was
like APPA what are you doing that's
soras smack across the face and then I
remember looking at him and it was just
quiet right we just looked eye to eye
and then he started to tear up and he
just
like I ruined my daughter's station
that's all that's what he was tear I
wanted to hurt Ed oh yo what the [__]
meth is a crazy truck dude don't dude
that's insane cuz I feel like with my
dad I mean I definitely was a crazy kid
so I understand but they didn't know how
to like manage their anger very well oh
yeah and it's just easier to bully
somebody who's smaller than them you
especially with my dad my dad's not a
big guy yeah so my dad my thing's like
come on man you know you ain't about
this life what are you doing why are you
doing this to me you I mean it's like if
I see you on these streets I'll
[__] I beat your well the thing is it's
like we got to remember too it's man
they were raised by our grandparents who
were yeah like War torn you know my
grandfather was a war criminal right I
mean so so like that's what they know
you know what I mean and and like they
they just kind of it was one of those
things where maybe they did think about
oh maybe I shouldn't be doing something
like this but then when that moment hits
you just kind of revert back to like
what you know right you don't think and
so like you might hit your kid you might
do something that yeah maybe you thought
I'm not going to do it like that but
they're not like really checking
themselves cuz their day-to-day is just
that [__] immigrant hustle they're
just making ends meet they're stressed
they're frustrated life what is that I
just [__] provide for the family and
then and then you little Shey come over
here trying to act like a little bad
well my mom today went I was on the
phone cuz uh I worked out like a couple
days ago and then I thought I had a
fever I was just sore I didn't tell the
difference cuz I was just in pain and I
told my mom mom I was like oh you I
called you I said why' you pick up I was
like Oh I thought I was sick and she
goes it must be nice not to not to work
when you're sick and I was like that's
what normal people what the [__] are you
talking about she goes what do you mean
I was like well I was like yeah well you
had a flu I remember you would go to
work just dying yeah cuz we had to make
end's meet I'm like it wasn't that
serious like you could have just a like
a half a day you know what I mean the
[__] is wrong with you but she looks at
me like I'm a [__] yeah cuz I feel sick
and I'm resting right I I woke up with
the flu one day it was so bad that I
didn't even have the strength to get on
the bus right and then my brother just
we shared a room my brother just left
without me anyway and then my mom comes
in and she starts screaming what are you
still doing here and I'm
like sick right she's like no we're
Korean I'm like what what the [__] does
that mean we go to work and we go to
school even if we're sick I was like
this is America welcome to America yeah
you know you don't do my son is a
gay oh he's are so gay my mom said you
have to at least show up and tell the
teacher you're sick and then you can
come home dude and I was like what she's
like get dressed I I got sent to [__]
school oh I'm sorry finished so I had to
get dressed my mom never takes me to
school she gets mad at me if I miss the
bus I had a walk but this time she was
willing to take me to school with the
flu to tell the teacher I'm sick and
then she'll be satisfied and then I can
go home the teacher was like what the
[__] are you doing here exactly they're
like why did you come here to tell us
you could have called us you could have
had a like your son is sick yeah I got I
got sent to school I remember when I had
chickenpox oh at the [__] fever my
mom said don't lift up your shirt and
show anybody you know I'm [__] at the
fever you know I'm sick I'm like these
fools also don't know anything about any
type of medicine they always act like
know just today before I came in the car
she was I was like oh I was like yeah I
thought I had the cold she goes you
should have taken your flu shot I'm like
what the [__] does the flu have to do
with the cold she goes same thing when I
get the flu shot I don't get the cold
I'm like listen here you [__] I was like
one's a virus the other one's a
bacterial what the [__] are you talking
about and she goes you don't know
anything you're dumb and I'm like dude
your older son is a nurse you could just
call him and ask and she goes you don't
know she goes you guys think you know so
much now that you're older I'm like just
look it up man just [__] look it up
thing like why do Korean people have to
like when they're old they just make
[__] up and it's the truth well it's not
them making [__] up in their mind it's
true it's it's like it's one of those
things where it's just kind of like
quote unquote conventional knowledge and
wisdom that they never fact checked and
so it's endeared the test of time in
their mind okay okay I I got a story for
that so we got to wrap up though this
episode's going long yeah we got do to
yeah we'll save for the next one well
anyways that wrap this episode of the
gesus bra podcast fast we're going way
past uh gesus bra every Sunday's at
12:00 p.m. secret society s c r TS o c
IE Ty
y.com to cap to to cop the clothes as
you see on him right here your podcast
uh Bible study at Momo Bible study at
Momo genius PR every Sundays at 12 p.m.
we'll see youall next time peace